oh I don't care who you are I don't care
what games you like but if you don't
groove at this intro you're doing it
wrong ah welcome back everybody to Doki
Doki cinnamon club literature Club thank
you we're gonna keep playing and I
highly recommend if you're a new that
you go and check out part 1 this is game
with build up you know you gotta get
there unity we know we have to go
through a certain point for things to
get things but you gotta get there to
experience the full range of emotions
really well-written really well done so
far I'm really enjoying playing this
game I'm trying to romance Yuri in this
section you have to pick words to make
Yuri happy which is the purple girl
[Music]
disaster hey she like they who would you
romance who's your favorite girl tragedy
how she likes tragedies okay who likes
climax I kind of want to click that just
to see hey URI confirmed best girl Rath
she likes that too and frightening she
likes that too I know what my [ __ ]
likes that's right I treat her right she
like socks okay nevermind disoriented
disarray contamination uncanny Doki Doki
Doki Doki is the sound of the heart I
think ya might say told me graveyard
like we say they're doing didn't they
say Doki Doki those crazy Japanese am i
right and I should have said that
no okay um sadness what anxiety crimson
cage misery what that I don't okay all
right
suicide yeah intellectual who watch Rick
and Morty hey Yuri confirmed best girl
come on get real here raindrops damn I
really nailed it another day passes and
it's time for the Club meeting already
I'm really excited to go to the club
I've always wanted to be part of a club
in a school so this is great for me I've
gotten a little more comfortable here
over the past couple days it's been two
days by the way entering the club room
the usual scene greet me tptp yo saiary
looks like you're in a good mood today
hey ingesting that you still you being
in the clear de team I see that's a
pretty simple thing to get you in a good
mood but I guess it's always the simple
things with you anyway
uh sorry one second sumimasen hello
speaking of speaking in which and kami
angry really came with me to be a snake
no thanks
wow it's not like him at all I have my
reasons
what is my reasons why don't we take a
look at your purse Erie City City no
reason really I just wanted to look at
it hey sorry nervous lead retrieves her
coin purse she fumbles with the latch
and gets it open then she turns it
upside down and lets its contents belong
to the desk only two small coins fall
out oh I see okay okay I knew it I could
see right through so you're a big beer
how did you even know it's it's simple
also I talked to Ken about the game a
little bit ken has played the whole game
already he said he didn't spoil anything
but I I went into the folder of the game
he didn't spoil this either I just felt
like checking it out cuz it's that kind
of weird game let's see if I can find it
one second maybe you don't care look I
was just [ __ ] around I'm like okay
wait why is the characters why are they
having an individual file that's weird
and what happens if I delete the file so
I made a copy of them just in case
my precious girls if you had enough
money in the first place you would have
bought a snack before coming to this
club room so either you're not hungry
and won an excuse to take a walk or you
plan to conveniently forget that you
spend all your money so that I would
lend you some but there's one more thing
you're always hungry and so that only
leaves the one option
it made me feel guilty if you feel
guilty that means you deserve to feel
guilty that makes sense
ha ha ha ha you recently giggles hey I
didn't notice she was listening in her
face is in her book as always ha ha I
wasn't listening to anything I was just
it was just something in my back let me
borrow some money
that's don't get me involved like that
Sayuri besides you should only buy what
you can responsibly afford she's so
responsible and frankly after pulling a
mischievous little stunt like that your
suffering is fair enough retribution
your suffering ah did I just I didn't
mean that
I got too absorbed into my book I really
like we need speaking men Yuri you
didn't even meet spirit if in theory
that's there's no way you could think
that you were ready and easily paid you
mean we have to keep the revolution the
revolution retribution bit coming from
you saiary I guess there's a little
devil inside of all of us isn't there
foreshadowing everybody
don't let her fool you minute in case
people are saying like also you already
know it's gonna be a creepy game it's
pretty obvious and just reading the
reviews of the game or anything like
that you can't avoid it going in but
either way I'm enjoying it even though
it's a regular story based game so far
and no hint for it to technically be a
horror game just a random thought Sayuri
knows exactly what she's doing after all
she told you guys she was bringing me to
the club before she even told me hey you
in it Kim if it weren't for the Cape
Kate so we had to trick netsuke Jamaican
dude come on give me some credit give me
more credit than that Sayuri that is a
slacker oh wow yeah I don't know where
Oh something smack say you're in the
face and tumbles look at the text cookie
sure enough it's a giant cookie rat in
plastic it's they forgot her name
nightmare situation rest abuse
retribution actually that one almost
worked very mad Sookie that's it I was
just gonna give it to you but then I
heard you blab about the cupcakes
it was totally where I've seen your
reaction though fiery hugs the cookie
jeez just eating Sayuri rapidly tears
open the wrapper and takes a big bite
sure good say or II suddenly clasp her
hands over her mouth and bibbity you're
going through all over just one cookie
my name is Mickey Mouse
matsing it takes a bite of our own
cookie
hey you look really good - Nikki Guinea
tree cheese beggars can't be choosers
uh-huh but yours is chocolate
yeah but do you think I gave you that
one why do you think I gave you sorry
baby Seamus win with me hey sorry gets
out of her seat and goes behind netsuke
then wraps her arms around her that is
so cute oh geez oh geez Rick I get it I
get it
cookie still in hand not to get reaches
up to nudge say Orie offer I'm her fairy
suddenly leaves down and takes a bite of
Nancy Keys cookie hey did you seriously
just do that
mouthful say or it rots away to save me
Yuri and I laugh as well jeez you're
such a kid sub-tabs Monica can you tell
Sayuri hey that's the gig Lance's ran
Monica isn't in the classroom huh
where's Monica anyway good question have
any of you heard have any of you heard
anything about her being late today eat
me yeah I haven't either
hmm that's a bit unusual okay of course
she's okay haha she probably just had
something to do today she's pretty
popular after all mmm you didn't think
she sees heaven
haha I wouldn't be surprised she's
probably more desirable than any and
then all of us combined excuse me
suddenly the door swings open semi messy
I'm sorry I'm super sorry ah there you
are I didn't mean to be late I hope you
guys weren't worth it or anything yeah
Monica choose the clip every boyfriend
and your sister Yngwie what boyfriend
what an F are you talking about
Monica quizzically glances at me never
mind that what held you up anyway ah
well my last period today was study hall
I read that wrong in my head to be
honest I kind of just lost track of time
that makes no sense though you would
have heard the bell ring at last at
least I must have not heard it since I
was practicing piano piano I wasn't
aware you play music as well Monica Wow
Sugoi desu Nia she is so amazing Monica
ha I don't really I kind of just started
recently I've always wanted to learn
piano okay you should please do be
pretty to me Nicky that's Monica looks
at me maybe once I get a little better
I will that sounds cool I'd also look
forward to it is that so in that case I
won't let you down bean soup I Wow
they all want me so bad this is just
like real life for me guys anime babes
left and right you don't understand my
struggle Monica smiles sweetly ah I
didn't mean any pressure anything like
that ah don't worry I've been practicing
a whole lot recently and I'd really love
the chance to share once I'm ready I see
in that caves best of luck
Thanks so I didn't miss anything did I
no not not not really I chose to leave
out sailors mischievous escapades
I'm sure not to give away enough
complaining to her in any way it looked
like everyone has already settled down
say already some I already finished her
entire cookie URIs back to her book and
Natsuki disappeared into the closet I'm
really curious to talk to URI a little
bit more but at the same time I would
feel bad for distracting her from
reading I catch a glimpse of the cover
of her book it looked like the same book
that she led to me more than that she
seemed to be on the first few pages oh
okay so this is because we did correct
with the diary I mean the poem I don't
know what it is huh
crap I think she noticed me looking at
her she sneaks on another glance at me
and her eyes meet for a split second but
that only makes her hide her face deeper
in her big sorry I was just spacing out
I'm not under this sensing I made her
uncomfortable oh it's fine
if I was focused and I probably would
have noticed in the first place but I'm
just rereading a bit of this so that's
the book you gave me right hmm I want to
read read some of it I wanted to reread
some of it not for any particular reason
sure Yuri sure just curious how come you
have two copies of the same book oh did
she buy the book for us your Easter
bicycle huh
well when I stopped at the bookstore
yesterday that's not what I meant
confer I mean I just happened to buy two
of them ah I say there's something
fairly obvious here that you're isn't
telling me but I decide to let it go
I'll definitely start reading it soon
I'm glad to hear once it starts to pick
up you might have a hard time putting it
down it's a very engaging and relatable
story it's that so what's it about
anyway well hmm Yuri closes the book and
scans her eyes over the back the book is
titled portrait of Marco
[Music]
okay it's not an actual no it is Boris
[Music]
Boris custard you know that's a painting
oh well there's an ominous looking eye
symbol on the front cover oh wait
all right I just wanted to make sure I
didn't I don't accidentally give
anything away basically it's about this
girl in high school who moves in with
her long-lost younger sister but as soon
as she does so her life gets really
strange she gets targeted by these
people who escaped from a human
experiment prison and while her life is
in danger
she needs to desperately choose who to
trust no matter what she does she ends
up destroying most of a relationship and
her life starts to fall apart that's
kind of that's kind of dark isn't it
Yura made it sound like it was going to
be a nice story so that dark turn came
it came from nowhere
ahaha URI gently giggles all of a sudden
are you not a fan of that sort of thing
pizza pie no it's not that I mean I can
definitely enjoy those kind of stories
so don't worry I hope so yeah I totally
forgot that URI is into those things
she's so shy and reclusive on the
outside but her mind seems to be
completely different it's just that
those kind of stories they challenge you
to look at life from a strange new
perspective when horrible things happen
not just because someone wants to be
evil but because they have their own
goals in their own philosophy that they
won't believe in
they then settling when you thought you
related to the protagonist they made out
to be an AE to be the nave one for
letting their one-sided morals it can't
read interfere with the villains plants
and I'm rambling aren't I not again
I'm sorry hey don't apologize I haven't
lost interest or anything well I guess
it's alright then but I feel like I
should like to know that I had this
problem well she just described the
whole plot as well of the book right
when I let things like books and writing
fill my thoughts I kind of forget to pay
attention to other people so I'm sorry
if I end up saying something strange and
please stop me from talking too much
that's I really don't think you need to
worry that just means you're passionate
about reading the least I can do is
listen
it's a literature Club after all huh
that's well that's true in fact I might
as well get started reading it right you
don't have to what are you saying just a
moment ago you were looking forward to
it let me just get the book I quickly
read through the book that I had put
into my bag all right it's fine if I sit
here right
oh I slip into the seat next sliding
into the DMS with URI ah yeah are you
sure you seem a little apprehensive but
that's a I'm sorry it's not that I don't
want you to it's just something I'm not
very used to that is reading in company
with someone
sokka well just tell me if I end up
distracting you or anything all right
I open the book and start the prologue I
still understand that you means what URI
means by reading in company it's as if I
can feel her presence over my shoulder
as I read it's not a particularly bad
thing maybe a little distracting but the
feeling is somewhat comforting URIs in
the corner of my eye I realized that
she's not actually looking at her own
book I glanced over it looked like she's
reading from my book instead semi-matte
said I was just you're it you really
apologized a lot don't you
I do I don't really mean to this is
sorry I mean here this should work right
I slide my desk until it's up against
yours then hold my book more between the
two of them ah I suppose so you written
timidly closes our own copy once with
such cute once we eat lean yeah once we
chili in a little bit our shoulders are
almost touching wow this is pretty hot
stuff here guys
it feels like my left arm is in the way
so instead I use my right hand to hold
the book open Oh put what are you gonna
put your left arm buddy ah I guess this
makes it kind of difficult to turn the
page is she going to turn the page for
us here kawaii desu nee Wow URI takes
her left arm and holds the left sided
for the book between her thumb and
forefinger how is this gonna be a horror
game
ah I do the same with my right arm on
the right side of the book that way
oh yeah cuz they turn the page the
opposite way that way I I turn a page
and ury slides it under her thumb after
it flips to her side or maybe they
inverted the picture I don't know
but in holding it like this we're huddle
even closer together than before
it's actually kind of distracting me
it's as if I can feel the warmth of
Yuri's face and she's in the corner of
my vision are you ready hey to turn the
page ah sorry I think I got a little
distracted for a second I glanced over
at your face again and her eyes meet I
don't know how I'll be able to keep up
with her ah that's okay you're not used
to reading right I don't mind being
patient if it takes you a little bit
longer it's probably the least I can do
so cute since she's since you've been so
patient with me yeah yeah thanks we
continue reading you're a no longer ask
me if I'm ready to turn the page instead
I just assumed that she finishes the
page before me so turn it by my own
volition we continue the first chapter
in silence even so turning each
patient's feel like an intimate exchange
my thumb gently letting over the page
lighting it flutter over to her side as
she catches it under her own thumb hey
Yuri this might be a silly thought but
the main character kind of reminds me of
you a little bit you think so
how does she well I guess she's more
blunt in a lot of ways but she also
second-guesses all the things that she
says in dense
like she's afraid she'll do something
wrong it's not like I can seem to your
head or anything but they're kind of
reminiscent of some of your mannerisms I
see here we remain silent for a moment
but pizza pay that's probably a terrible
thing to have in common with her
this is so embarrassing that you think
that wait I didn't mean in a bad way or
anything I'm sorry I didn't really know
you were self-conscious about that sort
of thing I guess it means that it's kind
of cute ah what are you saying all of a
sudden hi are you calling me here are
you okay everyone I think it's about
time we shared today's poems with each
other we might have have enough time if
we wait too long huh you ready exhales
spared from finishing her thought is
that a right Yuri you look kind of down
I'm sorry if you haven't been a been
looking forward to this uh it's not it
it's fine Yuri Lazer's hand from the
book causing it to close on top of my
thumb all right I guess I'll do some
more reading tonight or would you prefer
I only read it with you oh I guess I
don't have too much of a preference
either way
read it with her hmm in that case I'll
read a little more tonight it'll be more
fun to read with you after it picks up a
bit you know that's good reasoning
that's actually a good reasoning yet in
that case feel free to finish the first
two chapters in your own time
all right I'll stand up I make a mental
note or where I left off in that book
then slip it back into my bag
[Music]
it's poem reading time mother gosh
Kristin channel so every everyday
finishes with reading a poem this is the
second time we read the poems and it
really lets you understand their
individual personalities more I think we
should start with like we did last time
it's kind of a good order this way I
think so go it's a Orie and my god her
voice I'm glad Silvo your tone makes it
sound like you like yesterday's better
you know me look too well for my own
good
well don't just try to be nice about it
if I'm doing a bad job then I rather
just hear it no no I still like this
when it premise you know I wouldn't lie
to you put the pipe never ever yeah I
guess so what made yesterday its poem so
great compared to this one then a
teaspoon I couldn't beat but that's why
I just go with my heart if it makes me
few things then II miss period pain I'm
not sure that's exactly how it works
then again I guess conveying feelings is
pretty important part of this whole
thing yeah maybe
honestly I don't even know what kind of
writing you like in the first place why
don't you at least try giving it some
thought you want to repeat for me Yeah
right
but you're always thinking about other
people Oh click the wrong you need to
think about yourself once in a while if
you don't you might end up getting hurt
at some point we don't really know we
think what you mean big penetrated
keeping me well whatever
anyway let's see hmm
I can't feel like happy Pooh wait some
things that makes a pretty pitiful miss
it weren't for that right the word I'm
looking for
melancholy happy and sad I can't see you
liking something sad scary most things
when you have a little rain clear in
your head the same poem can help you
keep your include making Namecheap you
mean sorry
that's unexpectedly alright baby
did you read my poem milky you can be my
pony okay alright
[Music]
pedals off my scalp like the middle
cookie jar
it's the bigger place where I keep all
my dreams little balls of sunshine or
rubbing together like bundle of tea tea
and reach inside with my thumb and
forefinger and black when air is warm
and tingly but there's no time to waste
if I put in the butter to keep it safe
and if I put the bottle on the shelf
with all of the other parts happy
thoughts happy thoughts happy starting
bottles all in my room my college makes
me not the friends each bottle a star
length to make a mince them times my
friends feels a certain weight
then comes a band to save the day
my neighbor night after wait more dreams
friend after friend more bones deeper
and deeper my fingers call like
exploring a dark cave discovering the
secrets hiding in the nooks and crannies
digging and digging scraping and
scraping I blow Durst of my apparently
it doesn't feel like time leaves my
empty shell could you some more my
friends look through my luck front door
finally under eye opener and income a
frames and they come in such a hurry
tell me what my bottle says much I
frantically pulled up from the shelf one
after other hold in the mark to each and
every frame each and every bottle but
every time and that one girl shatters
against the tile between my feet happy
thoughts happy thoughts happy thoughts
insurance or love with the phone they
were supposed to pay for my friend my
friends who weren't smiley there was
shouting
blady something but all I hear is echo
echo
aigoo aigoo in famous it's actually kind
of deep I guess she said met
metaphorically using the cookie jar as
her emotions say or did you really write
this CD be my teen you three was gonna
read the paper beaver yeah but I mean I
didn't expect something like this coming
from you Monica
many who have been really in touch with
my feelings I see that it's almost kind
of creepy well not exactly maybe because
I'm so used to you being cheerful well
nevermind I'm thinking too hard about it
the point is it came by good so you
should be proud of it hey mate I feel
like it wouldn't mean to express bit if
this week it even helps me understand my
feelings a little pity
writing is like maybe you got pretty
passionate about this huh I hope you
keep it up don't get ahead of yourself
so I always always had a habit of
getting obsessed with something before
dropping it no were than a week later I
wonder if this is one of those times but
seeing the passion in her eyes makes it
hard for me to be pessimistic all right
I'm gonna Eureka's I don't think I can
do a high-pitched voice twice in a row
let's see what you've written for today
Yury stares at the poem with a surprised
expression on her face and do you like
it
pizza pie how did you pick up on this so
quickly just yesterday I was telling you
the kind of techniques worth practicing
maybe that's why you did a good job
explaining I really wanted to try giving
it more imagery imagiro yuri visibly
swallows even her hands appear sweaty
and not used to this used to what I
don't know it's fine take your time
Yuri breeze and collects her thoughts I
know that Yuri likes to think before she
speaks so I offer that patience to her
yeah just being appreciated like this I
guess it probably sounds really stupid
but sing someone motivated by my writing
it just makes me really happy
are you saying you never shared your
writing before Yuri nuts really I don't
believe it I really only write for
myself and besides people would just
laugh at me do you really think that
again Yuri nice huh even your close
friends Yuri doesn't respond to that I
wonder wife anyway do you want to share
the poem you wrote today yeah I do
if it's with you oh my
yeah there raccoon it happened in the
dead of the night while I was slicing
bread for a guilty snack my attention
was caught by the scattering of a
raccoon outside my window that was I
believe the first time I noticed my
strange tape tendencies as an unordinary
human I gave the raccoon a piece of
bread my subconscious well aware of the
consequences well aware that a raccoon
that is fed will always come back for
more the enticing beauty of my cutting
knife was to sympton the bread my hungry
curiosity the raccoon an urge the moon
increments his face and reflects that
much more light off of my cutting knife
their very same light that glistens in
the eyes of my raccoon friend I sliced
the bread fresh and soft
the raccoon becomes excited Oh perhaps
I'm merely projecting my emotions into
the newly satisfied animal the raccoon
is taken to following me you could say
that we've gotten quite used to each
other the raccoon becomes hungry more
and more frequently so my bread is
always handy every time I brandish my
cutting knife the raccoon shows me its
excitement a rush of blood classic
horror low vien conditioning I slice the
bread and I feed myself again
[Music]
what some raccoon and I was a little
more daring with this one than
yesterday's I can see that it's a lot
more metaphorical yeah I don't know if
it's my fault but I can't begin to
imagine what this poem is about that's
right it's a bit closer to my preferred
writing stack using the poem as a canvas
to express vivid imagery and conveying
emotions through them yeah if I take it
at face value then I can't even figure
out what it's supposed to mean well I
think it's something that different
people can relate to in their own way I
wanted to express the way it feels for
me to indulge in my more unusual hobbies
it's those sort of things
I usually force to keep to myself maybe
it's about her writing so I sometimes
enjoy writing about them why do you keep
them to yourself they because they're
embarrassing and people would make fun
of me don't you have anything like that
pizza pie well yeah I guess I do I feel
like everyone has a little something
like that
the best we can do is respect each other
and our individuality even if it's
difficult sometimes and some things
mixes are uncomfortable after all if I
hadn't learned to embrace my own
weirdness I would probably hate myself I
might be ranting a little bit now but
I'm glad that you're a good listener so
sweet
so pure so wonderful it's time for
Natsuki we haven't spoken to her much
hmm I like your last one better
hey really well I can tell you were a
little more daring with this foot but
you're really not good enough for that
yet it fell flat wow she is blood that
may be true but I wanted to try
something different I'm still frigging
this all out I mean I always like poems
that aren't trying too hard I hate when
people try sound fancy made more meaning
just by using annoying and complicated
language just make it simple cute and to
the point it's really funny how their
their personalities are reflected in
their poems and it's really funny how
I'm actually appreciating that is the
game about reading poems with girls it's
so tough but it's really entertaining
[Music]
Yuri's head-over-heels for all these
cryptic nonsense but I see right through
that bs making your reader look so hard
for all these deep meaning it's just an
excuse to have no meaning ah I guess
that's one way to look at it well
everyone has to want to be but my
opinion is the best opinion I'm sure you
figured that out already anyway here's
my poem maybe you'll learn something
ahem believe it if the music changes too
babyish Sam Amy likes Amy like spiders
you know what I heard about Amy Amy like
spiders icky wrigley hairy ugly spiders
listen why I'm not friends with her amy
has a cute singing voice I heard her
sing in my favorite lobster every time
she sang the chorus my heart would pound
to the rhythm of the words but she likes
spiders that's why I'm not friends with
her one time I hurt my leg
really bad Amy helped me up and took me
to the nurse I try not to let her touch
me
she likes spiders so her hands are
probably gross that's why I'm not
friends with her amy has a lot of frames
I always see her talking to people
she probably talks about spiders what if
her friends start to like spider steel
that's
I'm not friends with it doesn't matter
UCS other hobbies it doesn't matter if
she keeps it private it doesn't matter
if it doesn't hurt anyone it's gross
she's gross the world is better off
without spiders I'm trying to think of
it if it's something and my mind went
through that Amy likes other girls or
something like that like you know how
some people are really against that sort
of stuff or because she likes her but
she doesn't like this part of her that
she thinks is really filthy
not bad rate it's quite a bit longer
than yesterday's yesterday's yesterday's
was wait tissue I was just warming up I
hope you didn't think that was the best
I could do
no no of course not anyway the message
it's pretty straightforward in spun I
doubt I have to explain it sometimes you
can explain complicated issues with much
simpler analogies and it helps people
realize how stupid their being yeah yeah
that's true
like anyone would agree that the subject
of this poem is an ignorant jerk do you
know do you know people like that
of course it's about it how everyone
thinks mine it doesn't matter it can be
about anything is it about our
handwriting I wrote it to be easy to
relate to everywhere some kind of weird
hobby or a guilty pleasure okay wasn't
as deep as I thought something there
you're afraid if people find out they
make fun of you or think less of you but
that just makes people stupid who cares
when someone likes as long as they're
not hurting anyone
they makes them happy I think people
really need to learn to respect others
for liking weird things huh that's funny
Yuri wrote about something similar today
huh did you say Yuri
yeah she sent her poem was about unusual
hobbies of hers I didn't really get it
but she said something similar to you
that's that people shouldn't be
shouldn't make each other feel insecure
about those things really well I mean
Yuri's pretty weird so I wouldn't doubt
that she has come some weird hobbies not
that there's anything wrong with that
did she just expose herself with her own
poem it's not like I would judge her
anything
Matt's like he has trouble finding words
I guess that she try not to be so mean
to her that's funny
if she feels insecure about her we had
behavior since then I mean I always hate
people who make me feeling secure and
Yuri made me feel insecure yesterday but
but the way you put it it sounds like
she's starting her Lucy well I would say
so even if her writing style is really
different I'm sure she'll appreciate the
message in your poem it's what I do best
after all I don't like writing a list
there's a good message to take away from
me
like conveying emotions is important but
I want to make people think not just few
it's really interesting hearing there
are different perspectives on writing
cuz I when I when I hear her talk not
City that's a good talk I really agree
with her and what she's saying but when
I hear you explain her perspective I
really agree with what she's saying as
well so it's really interesting
remember they I'm gonna write a good
poem for tomorrow too so look forward to
it
who should I show my poem to next Monica
hi again Pittsburgh what's the writing
how's the writing going alright I guess
I'll take that as long as it's not going
back I'm happy you're applying yourself
maybe soon you'll come up with a
masterpiece I wouldn't count on that you
never know want to share what you wrote
today for today sure here you go I get
my poem to Monica all right great job
pizza Bank I was going oh in my head
while reading it it's really
metaphorical I'm not sure why but I
didn't expect you to go for something so
deep I guess I underestimated you it's
easiest for me to keep everyone
expectations low that way it always
counts when I put in some effort that's
not very fair well I guess it worked
anyway you know that Yuri likes this
kind of writing right writing that's
full of imagery and symbolism
unlike Sayuri who likes using simple
indirect words to describe happiness and
sadness Yuri likes it when readers are
left to derive their own meaning out of
it it's very challenging to write like
that effectively both allowing people to
get something out of it just feel or
letting them deeply analyze all of the
nuances it can take years of practice
which I'm assuming Yuri has said as at
this point I never really asked though
I'm sure I'm nowhere near her level yet
don't worry so much about that
you do your own thing just keep
exploring and learn by trying new things
but anyway you want to read my poem now
I like the way this one turned out so I
hope you do too
all right let's take a look save me the
colors they won't stop bright beautiful
colors flashing expanding piercing red
green blue an endless kaku kaku funny of
meaningless noise the noise
it won't stop violent grading waveforms
squeaking screeching piercing sine
cosine tangent like playing a chalkboard
on a turntable like playing a vinyl on a
pizza crust an endless poem of
meaningless load me
what
[Music]
load me
[Music]
save me load me
[Music]
save me and load me that is really
strange hmm it's even more abstract than
your last one huh I'm gonna say what the
[ __ ] ha ha I guess it's just the way I
write I'm sorry if you don't like it no
I never said that it's just a kind of
thing I never really seen before I guess
I kind of like playing with my space on
that paper is aware that I would love to
join this club and actually write poetry
I kind of like played with my space on
the paper choosing where and how to put
space words can totally change the mood
of the poem it's almost like magic the
way I wrote the lines really short makes
it feel like they're trying to speak
over the noise I see it's still hard for
me to tell what it's about though
sometimes asking what a poem is about
isn't the right question a poem can be
abstract as a physical expression or of
a feeling or a conversation with the
reader so putting it that way
not every poem is about something anyway
here's Monica's writing tip of the day
yay sometimes you'll find yourself
facing a difficult decision when that
happens don't forget to save your game
[Music]
you never know when you might change
your mind or when something unexpected
may happen
wait is this tipping even though about
riding what I'm Haven talking about haha
that's my advice for today thanks for
listening okay everyone we're all done
reading each other's poem right
I have something extra planned today so
if everyone could come sit at the front
of the room this is about the festival
well sort of do we really have to do
something for the first of all it's not
like we can put together anything good
in just a few days well we'll just end
up embarrassing herself instead of
getting any new members that's a concern
of mine as well I don't really do well
with last-minute preparations don't
worry so much we're going to keep it
simple okay
we won't need more than a few
decorations Sarah has been working on
posters and I've designed some pamphlets
we can keep on during the event okay
that's great at all but that doesn't
tell us what we're actually going to be
doing believe in ah sorry I thought you
heard about it already we're going to
keep we're going to be performing
performing right Monica yeah we're going
to have be having a poetry performance
each of us is going to choose a poem to
recite during the event but the cool
part is we're also going to let anyone
else come up and recite poems to say
auras putting in all the posters in case
anyone wants to prepare ahead of time oh
he's putting it in the older project
Sarah's been coloring a poster holds it
up for us to see are you kidding me
Monica you didn't you didn't already
start putting those posters up did you
and well I did do you really think it's
bad if that bad of idea well no it's not
a bad idea
but I didn't sign up for this you know
there's no way I'm going to be
performing in front of a group of people
like that I agree with Natsuki I could
never in my life do something like that
imagine it Yuri shakes her head in fear
good no sorry I understand where they're
coming from
remember that not seeking Yuri never
share their poems with anyone until just
a couple days ago it's a lot of them
it's a lot to ask for them to recite
their poems out loud to a whole roomful
of people I guess I kind of overlooked
that so I'm sorry but I still think we
should give it our best
we're the ones responsible for the fate
of this club if we start the event and
each other put on a good if we start the
event and each put on a good performance
then it will inspire others to do the
same and the more people who perform the
better we'll be able to show everyone
that what literature Lee club is all
about it's a bit expressing your
feelings being intimate with your same
friend and everything and having pain
that's right and it's those reasons that
we're all in this club today don't you
want to share that with others to
inspire them to find the same feelings
that brought you here in the first place
I know you do I know we all do and if
all it takes is standing in front of a
room for two minutes and reciting a poem
then I know you can do it
Matt Suki and Yuri remain silent Sayuri
looks worried I guess that leaves me no
choice I agree I don't think it's too
much to ask I think that's a Orion
Monica I've been trying really hard to
get new members the least we can do is
help them out a lot better
[Music]
it looks like Natsuki doesn't have any
arguments laughs okay poor Yuri though
that's gonna kill her I guess I'll just
have to get it over with
[Music]
re-roof thanks netsuke what about you
Yuri Yuri dejectedly glances run at
everyone else's expected faces I guess I
don't really have any choice have a
choice this club is seriously going to
be the death of me oh gosh
you'll be fine Yuri but anyway let's
move on to their main event I want each
of you to choose a poem of yours we're
going to practice reciting them in front
of each other no wait
Monica this is too sudden well if you
can't recite your poem in front of the
club how do you expect to do it in front
of strangers oh no don't worry I'll
start to help everyone feel a little bit
more comfortable
Kimmy Nicks of course now let's see
Monica flips through her notebook - to
the specific poem she has in mind for
herself then she then stands behind the
podium the title of this poem is the way
they fly I wonder if it will be another
weird breaking the fourth wall kind of
thing a hen Monica begins reciting her
plans her clear confident voice fills
the room more than that her inflection
is pristine she knows exactly how to
apply emotion behind each line she
recites bringing the words to life it's
this something she's done before or is
she simply a natural I glanced around me
everyone has their eyes on Monica Saira
looks amazed URI has an intense
expression on her face that I don't
understand finally Monica finisher there
the recite recitation the four of us
applaud Monica takes a deep takes a
breath and smiles
hey that was so good Monica ha thank you
very much
I was just hoping to set a good example
are you ready to go next Sayuri I'll go
next
what URIs fighter that bully Stephen
Yuri clashers a sheet of paper between
her hands and Santa keeping her head
down
she walks quietly quickly over to the
podium this poem is called Yuri
anxiously glances at each of us
you can do it Yuri so precious it's
called after image of a crimson eye
Yuri's voice shakes as she starts
reading the poem just a moment ago she
practically refused to do to this why is
she suddenly putting in so much effort
as Yuri gets past the first couple lines
her voice changes it's almost like what
happens when you read gets absorbed
absorbed into her books her quavering
words transform into sharp syllables of
a fierce and confident woman that's my
girl
the poem is full of twists and turns
into a structure that she onion unity
8ye and none Shu eighths I think I've
seen that word written before with
perfect timing this must be a rare
glimpse into her the whirling fire Yuri
keeps concealed inside her head suddenly
she's finished
everyone is stunned Yuri snaps back into
reality and glances around him she is as
if she bewildered even herself hi it's
up to me to save this situation I'm the
first one to start applauding everyone
joins me afterwards and we give Yuri
their recognition she deserves it's not
that we didn't want to applaud for her
but we were call it so up guard that we
must have forgotten I sweep laud Yuri
holds upon her chest and rushes back
into her seat Yuri that was really good
thank you for sharing
this day is so much longer than the
first two looks like your is down for
the count
okay I get them mixed in so Yuri helps
out of her chair and cheerfully walks to
the podium this one is called my meter
sorry I Keiko sorry how did you guys do
it so easy huh try not to think of it
like you're reciting to other people
imagine you were a setting it to
yourself like in front of a mirror or in
your own head it's your poem so it'll
come out the best that way I see I see
okay Sara begins her pond somehow it
feels like her soft voice was made as a
perfect match the poem isn't aimlessly
cherry likes a aureus it's serene and
bittersweet if I were to read this on
paper I probably wouldn't think much of
it but hearing it come from Sayuri's
voice almost give it a whole new meaning
maybe this is what she or he meant when
she said she likes my poems it's like I
get to reach more deeply into someone I
thought I knew through and through Sara
finishes and we applaud I did good job
Sayuri what does that even mean it came
right now so nicely Sayuri the
atmosphere of the poem fits you really
nicely but it might be that other poems
wouldn't work quite as well with that
kind of delivery
it really indeed in other words I've
seen poems of yours with where that sort
of gentle delivery wouldn't work as well
they might need a love more force behind
than depending on what you're reading oh
I see what you mean that's will I be
practicing that candy thing it's just
embarrassing to do it in front of
everyone yeah
next time I'm going to make you pick up
on that challenge you challenges you a
lot more we don't have much time before
the festival you know okay now who's
next
Natsuki don't make me go before PCB it's
not like I can compare to you guys
anyway Wow
- we'll get P D by P G PI lower everyone
see it is a little before every it's
it's fine it's fine I might as well get
it over with
but it's not like I have much of a
selection of what to read I just have to
go with what I wrote today I stand up
and step in front of the podium everyone
has their eyes on me making me feel
terribly awkward I recite my poem since
I'm not exactly confident in my own
writing it's hard to put energy into it
despite that once I finish I receive
applause anyway sorry I'm not really as
good as everyone else don't worry about
it so much I think it's less about your
abilities and more about your lack of
confidence in your writing that's
something that that'll improve over time
though yeah maybe
alright then that just leaves you
netsuke I'm doing Natsuki big grudgingly
gets out of her seat and makes her way
to the podium the poem it's cold it's
cold why are you looking at me because
you're presenting anyway from the
culture that's a key that's a key takes
a breath once she started reciting the
poem her sour attitude disappears too
long while she's still all on unfused
her poem has a rhythm and rhyme to it
it's not Sookie's trademark style and it
works surprisingly well when spoken
aloud
the words feel like they bounce up and
down and as if giving life to the pawn
Natsuki finishes and everyone applauds
she helps back to her see that wasn't so
bad was it easy for you did you see oh
you better not make me do that again
ah well do you at least feel prepared
enough to recite a poem in front of
other people I mean doing it in front of
other people will be way easier I can
put on whatever face I want for other
people but when it's just my friends
it's just embarrassing this is a
bracelet the King I think he it would be
the other way wait for me well well this
is how it is - well I guess in that case
you won't have much to worry about the
festival that said I want to thank
everyone for coming through it might be
hard but I hope you all have an idea
what it's like now make sure you pick a
poem and get enough practice before the
festival okay I'll be making pamphlets
so let me know ahead of time will you'll
be reciting jeez I should probably find
some other poem to residance then that's
fine too
doesn't have to be your own I'm already
pleasantly surprised that you're putting
in all this effort for the club it makes
me really happy
ah yeah no problem okay everyone I think
that's about it for today I know the
festival is coming up but let's try to
write poems for tomorrow as well it's
been working out really nicely so far so
I'd like to continue that as for the
festival we'll finish planning tomorrow
and then we'll have the weekend to
prepare Monday's the big game
I can't do this I can't I can do this I
can do this all right
I stand up there's no way I'll be able
to find some enthusiasm as Sayuri and
Monika but I'll do my best to get
through it if it's for the sake of the
club an impressing Monica then I'll have
to do my best
what so I care about Monica the most all
ready to go Sayuri yep look at you two
always going home like it's kind of
adorable isn't it yeah geez guys don't
make such a big deal out of it it must
be a little nice though well how am I
supposed to respond to that it's the KPG
but you don't have to be whatever let's
just go in go already and walk home with
Sayuri once more even though it's only
been a few days a lot of things I've
already changed but today say orys being
a little quieter than usual on the way
home
hey say ori3 we're speaking you oh no
wonder
I would think it about something
familiar like how we get to I mean CSI
or a phoneless with her words so let's
just say that Wendy Yuri asked to walk
home with you
oh she's jealous huh where did you what
kind of question is that you've kind of
putting me on the spot here
[Music]
okay
yeah
I'm gonna lie to her I mean obviously I
would welcome with Yuri but I would walk
home with Siri just to make her happy
you really think I would ditch you for
Yuri a bit she's so beautiful it's me
cheese I already see her in the club
every day besides you always seem to
really like going home together I
wouldn't just ruin that for you
you're so sweet bgp i think it made me
to my 15 here would deserve it if she
wanted it to sorry I already made up my
mind I really can't figure you ads
sometimes sorry
besides what's the point of speculating
something that's never gonna happen
hmm the conversation trails off it's
kind of weird
the thing that's Sara for Sara to care
so much about but I want to respect her
and keep her happy too
then again the festival is only a few
days away who knows what will happen in
that time okay that makes for another
day I'm gonna save over this one thank
you for watching another episode of Doki
Doki literature club it was literally my
pleasure.i time flight flew by by this
one Jesus I went so fast really enjoying
this we have been seeing some elements
of breaking the fourth wall we know
something is gonna change most likely at
the festival I can did spoil a little
bit said that on day 4 is when it really
gets weird which is the next one so
we're just gonna have to see what
happens then thank you for leaving a
like and showing all the support that
you do I really really really appreciate
it and I'm really glad I'm able to play
this for you guys on YouTube that's it
see you tomorrow SWAT fan